welcome to it very hastily thrown
together council geeks as you can see
from my lack of shaving but a bazillion
announcements have come out of DC and
Warner Brothers in regards to DC
properties hitting the big screen and we
can't not talk about this I think I
think we need to real quickly run down
the list of everything and ask because I
have a feeling we're going to be jumping
around so it's Suicide Squad 2016 yeah
2017 will be Wonder Woman and then
Justice League part 1 pearly 2018 is the
flash and Aquaman okay 20 19 is Shazam
and Justice League part 2 yeah and 2020
way up there yeah is cyborg and a Green
Lantern reboot I'm just remembering that
you know shortly before spider-man came
out so any major announcement we're
gonna have a spider-man movie every year
yes in addition to the proper sequels
rogram sinister six and then I'm then
we'll do a female spin-off at some point
and then amazing spider-man 2 came out
the world collectively went Nick we
don't want that yeah and they have done
so much backpedaling since then and if
dawn of justice doesn't connect they've
got five years worth of announced
features they're all of a sudden going
to be gone uh even if a lot of fans did
not accept man of steel they just had
they had to dig in there like we can't
wait two years and try this again we'll
try and improve as we go so I suppose it
makes the most sense to talk order of
release Suicide Squad which I assumed
would be a TV show because they've
already introduced all those characters
in arrow and it sounded like they were
setting it up for a spin off the this is
the same concern that I have with what
they're doing with the flash which is
that you're doing literally the same
thing in movies at the same time that
you're doing it on TV I mean this is
something that we brought up when we
talked about goth though I liked the
fact that it was completely different
from any version of bat
that will be done on film it's the same
reason they got away with having
Smallville while trying to get Superman
back from this big screen it was not the
same thing it wasn't even close but they
got the flash on TV just started this
year yes and they're gonna have the
flash in his own movie and I can't
imagine it's gonna be all that different
in terms of premise or approach are we
going to be forced to saying well what
is the real flat the real live version
live-action version of the flash is the
movie or is the TV show the other thing
with the with the Suicide Squad it
immediately rings the bell of Sony and
the Sinister Six yes to be fair um there
is more precedent for the Suicide Squad
holding their own as a story than the
Sinister Six yeah with the right
approach in the right tone I think
Suicide Squad could be a very fun movie
that will attract a lot of people who
might not get excited for traditional
Supergirl movies I think you could
approach us Suicide Squad movie like a
mission impossible meets Ocean's eleven
with people and garish costumes and
knives and guns and stuff like that and
that might be very fun and very
entertaining the Wonder Woman movie
comes out the next year after dawn of
justice so they will be filming that
Wonder Woman movie before Donald
justices in theaters so so so if dawn of
justice comes out and the world goes we
don't like that Wonder Woman they're
screwed let's be fair if they have one
up to marvel in announcing a female lead
superhero movie which Marvel still has
yet to do they've said they're going to
take the new 52 origin for Wonder Woman
which I have some issues with if they
just use her adjusted origin she's the
daughter of Zeus which I don't like but
you know they've got that am i okay fine
whatever but if they take on board the
other aspect of the new 52 which is that
she gets romantically paired off with
Superman I might lose my crack and just
assault the the movie screen that was
still image of wonder woman explained a
lot of my reservations about the
character and their approach to her
she's holding the sword mm-hmm I don't
like wonder woman with a sword it is
inherently a lethal weapon it is an
instrument of killing and death and I
think you know who would have a problem
with that Batman in super
now she's fighting monsters all time I
would be okay with but there was
something always likeable about the
lasso in that it was an instrument of
domination but also a sort of it was
non-lethal it was about connecting and
sort of forcing people to see evil in
themselves in terms of willfully
deciding to kill someone she's got a
higher body count than either Batman or
Superman Shane and I actually always
kind of liked that about her is that she
is more willing to bend on that rule
it'd be very easy to overplay that and
that would be a problem but it's and and
that's my favorite and I agree with that
she is from a warrior culture she has
different values than Superman or Batman
and I think she would say no the
quickest way to defuse this situation is
to just cut the head off I still think
she would see it as a last resort but
touching back on her getting paired off
with Superman I I suppose I the one
thread that I can hold on to that maybe
that won't happen is that they did
clearly set him up with Lois Lane in Man
of Steel now if they kill off Lois Lane
and dawn of Justice then then you know
they're pairing her him up with Wonder
Woman it's just it's such a bad coupling
bit neither of them benefit from a
Superman Wonder Woman coupling yeah she
looks inferior he's literally the one
human being on the planet that they
could pair her with that she is not the
power in that she is always in his
shadow and yeah wonder woman should
never be in the shadow of any man no
after wonder woman after wonder one is
2017 now we have the first Justice
League movie been officially announces
part 1 and part 2 and that's another
thing I'm scratching my head over for a
couple reasons the first is they're
having a two-year gap you're setting
aside how creatively bankrupt you may or
may not feel it is to break a single
story into two parts whenever it's done
part 1 part 2 are released within a year
or less of each other if it's
it is truly part 1 and part 2 of the
same story why are you putting two years
between them the leaks right now are
indicating Brainiac apart one dark
signer part two those don't sound like
two halves of the same story those sound
like two different stories so why are
you calling it part 1 and part 2 those
are very similar villains and very
similar threats to alien beings
threatening to take over the world owes
well I think well actually it'll it'll
be your second and third ones because
coming off of Zod right so edition which
apparently the latest rumor that I read
yesterday is that Zod's corpse will be a
big part of i read i read that this
morning all all i can make of that is
that Lex Luthor is going to reanimate
the corson that will be bizarro Superman
haha one thing that I am somewhat
cautiously optimistic about is there is
an element of their approach to these
Justice League movies that I do like and
it's different than what Marvel is doing
with their Avengers movies which is
releasing one every three years or every
two years and making it just a
standalone movie is that you don't tell
three different standalone Justice
League movies you tell one big epic
adventure spread out over three movies
more like the lord of the rings and the
first movie to give it room to breathe
would just be Superman and Batman
meeting for the first time and I thought
if you release it over three years as
three chunks of one bigger scale story
that would be something that is at least
different than what Marvel is open yeah
so it sounds like they're kind of do
that I'm sort of them adair they're
filming them back-to-back they started
off with a Superman Batman team up and
they're building the Justice League from
that so after 27 factor yes 2018 will
have the standalone flash movie that
we've talked about yeah presume he will
be in the first Justice may even have to
be in the there's never been rumored for
a long time that he would be in da of
Justice I don't think that's the case
anymore they did announce that he's
already been cast so I would not be
surprised if he shows up pre becoming
the flash right I don't know which
version I'm gonna say Barry Allen he's
the best known but right maybe that's
how the they'll try and get away with a
different movie because the TV will be
Barry Allen maybe they'll do Wally West
for the move
we are whatever regardless whoever he is
I have a feeling we'll meet that person
right briefly we'll get flash proper and
justice after or the flash we will get
our Aquaman movie yes um starring jason
momoa as Prince Namor the Submariner I
am an Aquaman fan but there was a big
part of his history in the comics where
he was kind of an angry marauding Viking
when you cast the guy who's best known
recently for playing an angry merani I
worried that they're not going to
deliver the Aquaman that I would prefer
so after that Shazam yes yeah which has
the rock as blackout you long sort of
been sought after for that role because
he looks like Black Adam he's sort of
pitch perfect I I would have been fine
with him actually playing Captain Marvel
or Shazam the main character because
there is a lovable like charming quality
to the rock when he smiles it lights up
the room I actually think he's a better
actor than he has even allowed himself
to be I would so I would really like to
see him stretch his legs and go really
fiercely villainous the script writer or
the director whoever they they've been
talked to has said that Shazam tonally
will not sort of reflect the darkness of
Man of Steel and what we've seen up
these Opie's yeah it'll be allowed to be
fun oh my god Shazam is about wish
fulfillment that's about an orphan kid
who gets to be the mightiest mortal on
earth it's that that should be a movie
that all ages can say yes other concerns
that I have about this property so if
they end up introducing Shazam into
Justice League part 2 i'm not interested
in Shazam fighting or teaming up with
Superman that today now they're very
redundant if anything it's like oh I can
do a Superman can do also lightning so
Justice League two walls have come out
in 2019 um if dark side is the villain I
think he's a pretty one note invader
kind of cosmic god of evil and war the
Avengers it has been said it like beat
DC to the same premise like years ago
because
first Avengers movie had an alien
invasion yes another dimension yeah and
had the main villain stealing people's
souls and brainwashing them mm-hmm
that's kind of dark side stick marvel's
got the jump on that too with with
Thanos because if we're being fair
Thanos was literally designed as a
knockoff of dark side but mainstream
won't care about the history they look
how about who they saw first right and
they saw Thanos first I think and Thanos
if he is still the big bad of Avengers 3
that's probably going to come out in
2018 a year before dark side shows up
and Justice League too yeah the last two
movies cyborg now you already said that
DC beat marble to the punch by
announcing the first villain or the
Philosopher's woman sameera cyborg would
be safar vanilla unless must Marvel
beats them with a Black Panther movie
the way up sort of the modern era yeah
cyborg would be the first now I I have I
have a feeling that that fact played in
heavily to the idea of even doing this
as a mood well the guy doesn't even have
his own comic no um they have really
been building his popularity over the
last couple years there is a lot of
logic behind his character today he is a
technology based hero he is all about
cybernetics and cyberspace and that is
the world we live in today he could tap
into a kind of a cultural zeitgeist at
the right time and be an unexpected
super popular hit you can look at as
well they're just going for diversity
for the sake of diversity um but who
cares if it if it still ends up bringing
a needed diversity to it after cyborg we
get the much needed Green Lantern reboot
there have been several Green Lantern's
throughout the comic history that they
could choose to focus on I would like to
see Jon Stewart well yeah okay now if it
is Jon Stewart then both of dc's movies
will they will start black superheroes
yes
that would be an interesting or they
could have al Jordan past the edge or
pass the ring on to either Guy Gardner
or kyle rayner with guy you have more of
a arrogant macho like hard-headed guy or
Kyle would be closer to the Peter Parker
type of carriera they may have a have a
hard enough desire to invalidate the
groove a Green Lantern movie that they
may reboot how Jordan just so they can
say that never happened and I would be
fine with that because Hal Jordan is my
preferred Green Lantern the movie will
come out 10 years after the last after
the last Green Lantern Lantern was 2011
and this will be 2020 that might be
enough time for the audience to have
just forgotten or deliberately wipe
their minds they opted not to reboot Hal
Jordan and they bring in somebody else
they kind of can't use Sinestro right
cuz Sinestro while he's been around for
other right other Green Lantern's heat
he's Hal Jordans villain right
ultimately right honestly it's what they
should have done in the first one
instead they opted for what they did my
cloud monster yeah cuz it worked great
for the second fantastic for her oh yes
iconic yeah it's funny talking it out
there or there are more potential bright
spots in this announcement then then
when I first tried to wrap my head
around it and my brain just kind of
melted ok I'm pulling for it to work but
I can see a lot of points word like just
look at that screw is loose at all the
whole things is going to be the
different yeah the difference is if
Marvel Studios unveiled their five-year
plan with 10 movies lockdown we would
say cool we're excited for all of them
if Marvel has earned that everything
hinges on dawn of justice and their one
shot to sell to us that they can make
this work their base they're basically
opting to make the Avengers as their
second right film these are characters
that I love these are characters that I
have wanted to see in movies for most of
my life the problem is they're all sort
of blossoming out of one movie that I
hated and that has sort of tarnished my
expectations for what I will get I am
morbidly curious about da naboo
and unfortunately because that's the
entry point for everything else is hard
for me to get any level of excitement
for anything that is supposed to spring
out of that beyond just a theoretical I
would like a Wonder Woman movie that is
a fact regardless of who is it i would
like one but I started looking at the
specifics of what I look to be getting
and then my expectations start it is
like a soufflé deflating I think for now
that's that's about all we have the
energy for so thank you for joining us
and until next time this council is
adjourned